I I used to think when I was like really
young doing YouTube that I would make it
if that ever happened if I got on TV
right and now it's like there's I have
so many emails being like do you want to
come on this or do you want to do this
it's just like it's things have changed
so much now where
YouTuber holds so much more power over
this old like dinosaur sort of age thing
yeah I mean like anyone any do you can
you think of any YouTubers who have
actually made like a good TV program
no no
um I'm trying to think no problem
smiling friends is the only one I can
smiling friends yes
but aside from that it's what I feel
like animation is a very unique case
where it would kind of benefit from
being in like a classic TV production
cycle with the money and and yeah
support around it a lot of shitty movies
on YouTube as well like yeah it goes
both places but but like what what I
always see happen is is that they get
the TV deal and then their YouTube
content just like goes down in quality
they start losing you know we know a few
people that have ruined it well not ruin
it but like taking that route and it's
just like you watch it from a distance
you're like why would you do work as
your agents like hey this is a good idea
this is this is really legitimize you
it's like yeah
they held the cards and now it's like
you hold the cards you can do to decide
whatever you want to do with it and
everything is becoming so integrated
with
the sort of stuff that we're doing on a
platform that we've been part a part of
so long that we can help sort of
pave the way yeah exactly exactly yeah
because colder ones have a vision
is there an end goal the vision's kind
of blurry
depends if you ask them drunk or so yeah
hold on to the movie bro the drunk
version get your cockat
um Chad guess he's dick and ass out at
the same time in one frame with a mirror
how many places in the world can I get
my dick out that actually would I would
click that if I saw him I recommended if
I saw a video that said how many
countries can I get my [__] and balls
out 24 hours I would [__] watch I
wish he could make [__] like that still
I wish YouTube would not throttle that
sort of content you could never do that
but yeah even if but if you bought like
if you went back a couple of years in
time you could make that but still blur
and it wouldn't get [__] but yeah yeah
now it's like there's no way your
channel
how does cold one survive in that kind
of yeah
[Music]
every five seconds there must be a
jarring cut that's why that's why it's
four hours of footage cut down to 15
minutes it's 15 minutes we are still we
are we do still have problems with
things in that but I think YouTube was
going down this
path where it was becoming more and more
narrow with what was allowed to be done
uh to the point where I would get like
if I go on my YouTube app and log into
my main Channel every single video now
is yellow or red dollar signed because
what was okay back then has slowly
shifted yeah and you still get punished
for stuff that they said was fine back
then and that still was narrowing and
narrowing for a while but then I think
it started to open up again for a bit
like YouTube they chilled out a little
yeah they made some things being like
yeah again recently yeah but it's weird
it's like they always bend one rule but
then they it's it's they do both at the
same time they say you can do this now
but now it really feels like if you get
on their radar you just get [__] well
they just want to like like that's like
one of my fears as well where I where I
look at the videos I'm like you know
what we're doing is okay now but I don't
want to like two years from now then
like do a review on that that's it [__]
this whole Channel because over the
years we've changed so much we haven't
penalized the content we haven't like
ruined the content but we've found other
ways of doing stuff where it's still on
their guidelines and we're constantly
changing and there's some videos that we
have age restricted because of it which
is completely fine I love you YouTube
um but yeah it's just like uh I I try to
steer away from trying to drink as much
on videos because I don't want someone
to reveal one day and go well it's just
them getting drunk and getting their
[__] out it's not that is first thing
called patreon there is there is one
video you did
but we're not going to smoke crack pipes
anymore this little video you did where
you just
you just like ordered like 500 [__]
ubereats oh yeah
I imagine you must have got so many
comments being like what a waste of food
well we come from the era of
collaborating with how to basics uh that
was already just like uh and you got the
[__] ubereats driver to join you oh
yeah like that's what I mean you think
we just convinced the first guy we tried
like 10 guys before yeah I can imagine I
can imagine yeah but everyone's like I
don't believe it they were trying to pay
them as they put their head into the
room and they were all just so scared I
would be [__] scared if I walked in
the room two drunk men with 100 [__]
cheeseburgers on the table no it was 100
slices of cheese okay they were all
divided up into separate components I
feel like that those videos never
reached their potential of what I
envisioned them to be
what's the vision
I just I just thought it would be funny
there would be funnier stuff that you
could ask them to make or something and
they were all just like but it was just
yeah it was just little it every video
sort of just ended up well I guess we'll
just order a hundred of this one item
there and then eat it and then it also
would be three and a half hours or four
hours in the recording drunk or like oh
how many more times we have to try to
get some guy out of trouble yeah like
when you ordered it must have been like
two [__] hours before it showed up
there were some good parts in those like
getting people to draw stuff on like the
Domino's box and stuff like that yeah
but yeah
[Music]
[__] out of like a big trough like a
mukbang almost yeah have you guys ever
needed to scrap a video because he got
two [__] face
podcast that's my fault
or whatever
okay yeah the guess the guests got too
drunk and we didn't record enough and
then I was drunk talking to another guy
there and I was like I don't want that
[__] conversation like don't talk
about Kanye West for an hour
so you're saying that
I saw the dollar signs and I was like we
need to shove as much [__] up your ass
every episode is possible and
last time we filmed you completely
unprompted because we had we've got this
giant wheel
that um we put in this it's it's that
wasn't my [__] that was my name shut
up let me talk
it looks it's a [__] awesome wheel
you spin it and there's like a
punishment on it or something and one
was like rat trap or mouse trap I put my
fingers in a mouse trap and then Chad
completely unpromptu was like oh we
should put my dick in it
and mostly everyone there was like that
does not sound safe no like that sounds
like a really bad idea anyway Chad was
very very confident that he could put
the head of his penis in the actual
thing so it's a snap on the end of this
[__] and I did and and no one could talk
you out of it basically so I don't know
why you're saying that I'm listen the
patreon numbers are down all right so
you put it in it just yeah thankfully it
caught a bit of my shirt I was slapping
down so it wasn't as painful but you
Afflicted the knob but I got flicked in
the knob it didn't hurt as bad as I
thought it would thankfully but it still
[__] hurt I love the fact that you
thought it would hurt more and yet you
still did it
is there anything you would not do yeah
there's got to be a limit yeah there
must be a limit there must be that's too
far for you what's too far for anything
here
that'll never be a tear on our patreon
anyway
yeah
yeah to be like all for it but now I'm
like I'm saying I have a saying I'm
getting a bit older it's like there's
now some things I'm like I ain't doing
that like I'm like can we change my name
already yeah yeah
getting old but there's still a lot of
stupid [__] I'll do but there is some
conversation we've had in the office
like
should we do that should we I'm like I
don't think I can do that so
like what wait
have you draw the line off the top of my
Dome I know I've been through like first
and I'm like okay I know my buttholes
and then I see the patreon guy down like
that's it
here we go again round two
promptly what decided was you wanted to
shove it up my ass mostly
yeah
that's a tiny bit but I was not sure no
I was always like if it's something that
makes you actually uncomfortable it's
not something you're not like being
poured out but then yeah like I'm saying
you recently started being like no we
need to start whoring me out
there was like a phase where I was like
maybe we should stop and I was like hold
up the numbers are going down let's do
it more every episode I don't know the
numbers just naturally go down just yeah
I guess but we're posting so much on
there now that's a another conversation
we got a podcast and a gaming series on
there now yeah but how many people on
patreon yeah not enough buttholes
we're trying to build build out the
catalog so then we can finally promote
it properly because we haven't really
given it much promo on the actual
Channel but we want to do like a proper
this is what's on our patreon a full
upload there's people on the patreon
here like what is this gaming [__] I
wanted buttholes yeah
well and it's like a main Channel video
sort of I don't know if it's the same
with you guys but our patreon is like
just essentially like it fun it's enough
money to fund everything so we're
actually like turning some profit but it
means we can
do something because spend some kind of
video and not think about it because we
know we've got this patreon yeah yeah
yeah like for us our patreon is just for
like really really big ambitious
projects that we have in mind and then
the podcast kind of just like runs
itself at this point yeah it's just like
okay patreon for like extra extravagant
stuff and then normal podcast just to
keep going but there's a lot of stuff
that we have in videos that we'd like to
keep in the main Channel video but
because you know kids in their Tick Tock
and they're like really ADH so we have
to keep videos really engaging from
start to finish yeah the Mr Beast method
yeah so there is some stuff that we'd
love to leave in the videos but it's
just like there's no way to Loop it in
and make it engaging because like the
punch line leading up to that is a
minute of us explaining like okay now
for this next punch line Max is going to
grab the camera and he's gonna you know
but we could essentially have a second
channel for gaming and stuff like that
yeah we don't want to like spread
ourselves on doing 300 different
channels like Smosh games so we're just
like yeah I think if you don't do that
right people get sick of you yeah like
there's obviously there's an argument to
be made either side like Mr Beast does
like as much as possible but I think if
you see
someone's face come up too many times
it's like oh the gaming channels they've
got second Channel they're doing Vlogs
they're doing this they're doing that
constantly yeah it can run like a little
thin I think there's a way to Market it
like with what we're doing where people
feel like it's an event yeah oh they
finally posted a video because like
overexpect uh it's definitely a thing
that can happen yeah especially like I
feel like some YouTubers brands are like
the kind of like the Mystique around
them you know every time I see like a
instant historian video for example
right yeah [__] it's like everybody stop
everything stop everything
that's it we just want to have something
that we upload and we're like really
proud of and anything else that we want
to do on the side because obviously
we've had yeah oh you know want to make
some extra money let's do a gaming
channel but then just like oh [__] it
we'll just put it on patreon payroll if
people want to see us
kick back play some games they can pay
to see it yeah again I will pay to see
you drunkenly analyzing anime as you
want we have done similar patreon videos
where we've uh it's called down the
rabbit hole we have a series where we
just like go on the internet and we just
start watching the most [__] just
watch down the rabbit hole Yeah
so I mean I'll do that next time we'll
do a reaction One anime episode Bro [__]
Yeah I would actually pay to watch that
yeah that would be okay that's it give
me your money right now